[Music]
stay
put
tell you got
[Music]
that
run
run do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you put on the earth
to do the one where it's like everything
inside you is moving together in harmony
with the
universe me neither but you know one can
hope
right wave to Mommy cuz she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it has I'm running a business
and right now that business is getting a
journalist in an out of
palonia no it's a oneoff no no and no
who's a journalist I have resigned my
position here at ni 20 grand says you
are welcome to palon president fega so
nice to meet
you we must take a selfie um you
approved it's
great
us ow what the hell just happened your
one man's security detail happened he's
a you I'm with the president of a
country in the middle of a coup this is
the scoop of a lifetime you got to be
alive to have the scoop of a lifetime we
never should have come let's go you
can't just leave
[Music]
him run
run ready to go I don't know how to stop
when you started the botom only I'm just
doing my
job
do you need help I get up again then I
got to win I get up again then I got to
win what nothing you still excited to
cover a coup less and less
honestly where is
vas here is vas go for hey not the time
for coaching
man oh my
God Color Me impressed Mr Petit not P at
all tell me you got that
[Music]
run